toutes celles et ceux qui en subissent
les effets au quotidien et voient leur
liberté leur dignité menacé par des
actes et des comportements qui sont
contraires à nos principes républicains
ces principes c'est notamment le respect
de la dignité humaine celui de la
liberté d'expression de pensée de prier
l'égalité entre tous et particulièrement
entre les femmes et des hommes les
droits de l'enfant notamment à
l'éducation et plus généralement le
refus des comportements dégradants
c'est aussi évidemment la laïcité
grandes valeurs de notre république dont
nous célébrons aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire de la loi fondatrice la
laïcité assure à chacun la liberté de
croire ou de ne pas croire aide assure
aussi la distinction entre la sphère
privée et la sphère publique en
garantissant qu'aucune religion quelle
qu'elle soit ne puisse régir les
pratiques et les règles collectives
notamment dans l'espace public
depuis plusieurs années ces principes
font l'objet d' attaques répétées
insidieuse de plus en plus nombreuses
qui affaiblissent notre capacité à vivre
sereinement les uns avec d autres dans
le respect la reconnaissance des valeurs
communes ce sont des enfants qui sont
retirés de l'école pour recevoir une
éducation communautariste ce sont des
associations sportives qui conduisent
des actions de prosélytisme religieux ce
sont des actions des associations
cultuelles qui deviennent des relais
d'influencé étrangères défiant les lois
de la république
ce sont des services publics dans
lesquels les principes de neutralité et
de laïcité sont méconnus comme l'a
indiqué le président de la république
lors de son discours prononcé aux
mureaux
le 2 octobre dernier il est important de
nommer les choses
le travail de sape que je viens de
décrire et bien souvent le fait d'une
idéologie pernicieuse portant le nomme
d'islamisme radical
cette idéologie a pour objectif de
diviser les uns et les autres et de
répandre dans la société la haine et la
violence c'est ce que nous appelons le
séparatisme elle est d'autant plus
dangereuse qu'elle est la manifestation
d'un projet conscient théorisé politico
religieux qui a pour ambition de faire
prévaloir les normes religieuses sur la
loi commune
elle est organisée de façon méticuleuse
elle se sert des failles de notre
arsenal juridique pour prospérer
elle est parfois articulé avec le
concours de l'étranger et s'appuient
souvent hélas sur des citoyens français
face à cela la république entend se
défendre et elle ne le fera pas en se
repliant sur elle-même en continuité et
cohérence avec les dispositions prises
depuis le début du quinquennat
ce texte doit permettre de donner à
l'état de nouveaux moyens d'action afin
de mieux garantir le respect de ces
principes
ce projet de loi n'est pas un texte
contre les religions ni contre la
religion musulmane en particulier c'est
à linverse une loi de liberté
c'est une loi de protection c'est une
loi d'émancipation face au
fondamentalisme religieux et plus
généralement face à toute idéologie ou
dérives qu'ils poursuivraient les mêmes
finalités
pour y parvenir le projet de loi
poursuit deux grands objectifs garantir
le respect des principes républicains et
le libre exercice du culte
sur le premier volet la loi donne des
services de l'état de nouveaux outils
pour renforcer la neutralité du service
public et garantir que les associations
respecte les libertés fondamentales des
mesures importantes sont prises dans le
champ de l'éducation afin d'assurer que
chaque enfant bénéficie d'une indique
d'une éducation conforme aux principes
de la république
de nouvelles dispositions sont
envisagées pour que l'on puisse
combattre plus efficacement les discours
de haine sur les réseaux sociaux
sur le deuxième volet le projet de loi
vise à adapter au temps présent la
grande loi de 1905
tout en respectant strictement le
principe de séparation entre les églises
et d'état le texte procède à une
modernisation et à une clarification du
régime des cultes
il assurera une plus grande transparence
de leurs sources de financement afin de
lutter contre les influences étrangères
il dote également les préfets de moyens
renforcés pour qu'il puisse agir encore
plus rapidement et plus efficacement
lorsqu un lieu de culte devient un lieu
de diffusion de discours incitant à la
haine et à la violence
agrégé ces dispositions viennent
renforcer les moyens d'action de l'état
au plus près des territoires dans une
logique de prévention
ce projet de loi modifie certaines des
grandes lois de la république notamment
la loi de 1901 relative à la liberté
d'association
la loi de 1905 relative à la séparation
des églises et de l'état auquel nous
sommes collectivement très attaché ces
évolutions sont rendues nécessaires par
l'évolution des moeurs des pratiques ou
des menaces auxquelles nous faisons face
ces modifications doivent permettre de
donner à ses lois davantage de force et
de les adapter au temps présent
mesdames et messieurs le texte que j'ai
de grands honneurs avec le gouvernement
de vous présenter aujourd'hui est un
texte qui vise à protéger tous nos
concitoyens
c'est un texte qui s'inscrit dans la
grande tradition des fondateurs de notre
république puisque c'est un texte pour
renforcer l'effectivité de nos libertés
publiques et individuelles liberté
d'association liberté de conscience
liberté d'expression liberté de culte
qui doivent plus que jamais être vécue
dans leur plénitude par chacune et
chacun d'entre nous ce projet de loi
enfin s'inscrit dans une stratégie
d'ensemble
il va de pair avec une action déterminée
structurel de longue haleine pour que la
promesse républicaine d'émancipation et
d'égalité des chances soit une réalité
pour tous comme l'a rappelé à plusieurs
reprises le président de la république
ce projet est ainsi au coeur du travail
gouvernemental conduit depuis 2010 est
il passe par l'activation de tous les
leviers de l'action publique afin de
renforcer notre pacte républicain
voyez bien la cohérence de notre action
le projet de loi prévoit ainsi une
disposition permettant d'interdire le
recours à des écoles clandestines qui
propagent l'idéologie de l'islamisme
radical et en parallèle dans les mêmes
quartiers les plus concernés par ces
agissements nous avons des doublé depuis
trois ans dix sept mille classes
primaires dans les écoles de la
république ce qui a profité à 300 mille
enfants nous y avons également favoriser
le développement de l'offre de soins
avec la création de maisons médicales
supplémentaires
nous y avons déployé 50 ou trois
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
avec une augmentation inédite des moyens
de la police de la gendarmerie et de la
justice
là où ils sont les plus nécessaires nous
allons également construire davantage de
logements en particulier de logements
sociaux mieux répartis sur tout le
territoire afin de rompre avec les
logiques de ghettos c'est pourquoi j'ai
demandé à emmanuelle wargon ministre
délégué en charge du logement de me
faire des propositions pour poursuivre
et prolongée des efforts de construction
de logements sociaux et renforcer la
prise en compte des enjeux de cohésion
sociale dans les politiques
d'attribution le parlement en sera saisi
le moment venu je vais laisser
maintenant la parole au ministre qui
m'entourent pour qu'il vous présente
plus en détails des dispositions de ce
projet de loi je souhaite les remercier
pour le travail de préparation intense
et de concertation qui l'ont conduit au
cours des derniers mois
c'est particulièrement le cas du
ministre de l'intérieur
mais je pense aussi à beaucoup d'autres
membres du gouvernement qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui présent à mes côtés mais qui
ont apporté sous mon autorité et ma
coordination leur précieuse contribution
à ce travail collectif à ce travail
majeur pour les valeurs de notre
république
je demande au ministre de l'intérieur de
bien voulu revenir au pupitre
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs ce texte de loi
travaillez vous l'avez dit monsieur
promise depuis de très nombreuses
semaines en interministériel en
remerciant toutes les administrations
mais aussi très largement consulté avec
les représentants des cultes des
courants philosophiques des partis
politiques représentés à la semaine
nationale et au sénat qu'ils soient de
la majorité ou de l'opposition des élus
locaux a reçu un avis extrêmement
positif du conseil d'état alors que vous
l'avez dit plusieurs libertés
fondamentales plusieurs principes
reconnus par les lois de la république
étaient concernés et c'est fort de cet
avis que nous présentons que nous avons
présenté au président de la république
le conseil des ministres ce projet de
loi ce texte de loi s'inscrit évidemment
dans les grands principes républicains
mais aussi dans les grands moments de la
république et vise à trouver secouriste
brillant disait à la tribune de la
chambre des députés lorsqu'il présenta
le texte de 1905 puisque nous sommes
aujourd'hui 115 ans jour pour jour après
cette présentation de la loi dite de la
séparation des églises et de l'état que
c'est un texte qui vise à pacifier les
esprits et a redonné force à la
république il n'est pas beaucoup de
moments monsieur le premier ministre et
je vous en remercie de la confiance que
vous avez su m'apporter avec madame la
ministre déléguée et bien sûr avec le
président de la république ou lorsqu'on
est élu en l'occurrence maire d'une
commune qui connaît à la fois les
promesses de la république mais aussi
ses difficultés
on se dit que ce que l'on constate sur
le terrain on aimerait pouvoir les
changer profondément pour l'ensemble du
pays c'est ce que j'ai l'honneur de
mener avec marlène au ministère de
l'intérieur
six points rapides touche ce texte je
voudrais aborder deux ceux des services
publics et ceux des cultes je laisserais
marlène schiappa le soin d'évoquer le
sujet très important du monde associatif
et également du sujet autour de la
dignité de la personne humaine et
notamment la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires ou idéologiques
bien sûr ma chemise et glaciaux
nationale et monsieur garder soit qui je
remercie du travail quotidien nous avons
jusqu'à présent aborderont les sujets
qui concernent directement
les propositions qu'ils ont pu faire les
premiers articles du projet de loi
évoque la force corps à la république
pour éviter la propagation des
idéologies religieuses afin de laisser à
la religion le soin de s'occuper de
religion et l état le soin de s'occuper
des affaires de la politique
l'article premier du projet de loi
évoque un sujet particulièrement
important qui concerne toutes les
collectivités locales de france qui
concerne des centaines de milliers de
personnes et d'habitudes de vie de tous
nos concitoyens
il s'agit d'étendre aux délégations de
services publics les transports les
piscines les marchés par exemple vos
concessions de service public et aux
organismes ayant une mission de service
public pôle emploi la caf la cpam
l'ensemble des offices qui travaillent
de manière étendue dans l'action
publique
les devoir de neutralité qu'on impose
aux agents publics pour être extrêmement
précis il ne sera plus possible de
constater des comme les comportements
communautaires ou des port de signes
religieux pour ces agents qui
travaillent au nom du service public
mais ne sont pas directement un agent
public au sens fonctionnaires du terme
c'est une démarche extrêmement
importante mais ce n'est pas pour rien
que c'est l'article premier du projet de
loi que nous vous présentons le deuxième
sujet c'est de permettre au préfet
évidemment d'intervenir comme ils
interviennent dans le logement social
lorsque les collectivités locales
connaissent ici ou là des difficultés
pour faire imposer les valeurs de la
république et pour faire respecter ces
valeurs lorsque par naïveté ou parfois
avec des questions que nous sommes posés
récemment lors des dernières élections
municipales il ya manifestement des
atteintes graves aux principes de
laïcité et des atteintes graves aux
principes républicains
nous avons écouté le conseil d'état et
nous avons choisi de proposer en effet
qu'un référé liberté
le préfet pourra saisir évidemment le
juge qui seul administratif pourra
décider de la continuité ou pas de
l'action entreprise par la république
dans les alertes ainsi en va des
règlements intérieurs pour les piscines
réservées aux femmes pour des raisons
religieuses par exemple qu'ils pourront
être immédiatement déférés s'attendent à
que d'actes unilatéraux qui serait
contraire aux principes républicains
enfin
sans détailler trop le projet de loi il
y a évidemment beaucoup de mesures
validées par le conseil d'état pour la
dissolution ou la suspension des
activités associatives pas simplement
cultuelle parce que celles ci sont
confondus du communautarisme
deuxième sujet je voudrais évoquer avec
vous c'est effectivement ce qu'a dit
monsieur le premier ministre malgré les
17 po diffic à sion depuis 1905 de loi
de 1905 il s'agit du moment le plus
important dans le renforcement de
l'esprit de la loi de séparation des
églises et de l'état
singulièrement pour aider les
associations cultuelles à ne pas être
confondus avec des endroits où ce prône
la haine le racisme ou les difficultés
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui pas
simplement sous un thème religieux
mettant un terme de séparation
révolution s'il en est désormais les
cultes devront demander en proposant
l'autorisation d'ouverture d'un lieu de
culte par une déclaration validé par le
conseil d'état qui est valable cinq ans
le principe road est un lieu de culte ce
qui n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
le deuxième sujet montrent en effet
l'importance que nous accordons à la loi
de 1905 en forçant toutes les
associations cultuelles qui sont
inscrits en termes culturels c'est en
1901 à passer en 1905 92% par exemple
des lieux de culte musulmans sont gérés
en association culturelle notre désir
c'est qu'elle fasse parler le principe
de la loi que nous évoquons un mât pas
vers l'association dit 1905 et que ces
associations doivent connaître avant de
faire des déductions fiscales des
experts comptables saison du financement
étranger elle doit absolument le déclaré
je remercie d'ailleurs bruno le maire et
les services de bercy pour le travail de
la dgfip le trac fin pour mieux
contrôler et pour mieux accompagner ses
associations et également de pouvoir
faire fermer un certain nombre
d'endroits que nous pouvons considérer
comme séparatistes non plus simplement
lien avec les rp c'est à dire le fait
que le local et/ou pas aux normes ou en
lien avec le terrorisme mais bien en
lien avec ce que nous appelons
l'idéologie singulièrement de l'islam
politique mais qui concerne évidemment
toutes les dispositions pour reconnaître
tous les cultes enfin des dispositions
favorables au culte est alors
financement national
ne veut pas dire de financements publics
sont mis à disposition et ont été très
largement demandé depuis très longtemps
par les divers cultes que nous avons
évidemment consulter
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
demain dans la miss aux délégués marlène
schiappa devenir si elle le veut bien au
pupitre présenté quelques articles du
texte avec plaisir merci monsieur le
premier ministre
bonjour à toutes et à tous auprès du mit
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin j'ai eu à
travailler sur deux aspects principaux
de ce projet de loi
je voudrais les partager avec vous
d'abord le premier concerne la question
des associations et du contrat
d'engagement sur les principes
républicains sur les valeurs de la
république nous avons décidé avec jade
arman raysse c'est ce que nous proposons
dans ce projet de loi sous l'autorité du
premier stress du présent la république
de faire en sorte que lorsqu'une
association sollicite une subvention de
l'argent public qu'il s'agisse de
subventions de l'état ou de subventions
des collectivités locales ou même de
mise à disposition de lieux qui ne soit
pas de l'argent sonnant et trébuchant
mais qui soit la mise à disposition
d'une salle par exemple eh bien nous
demandons à ces associations de
s'engager à respecter les principes
républicains
nous avons fait ce travail sur la base
du modèle de ce que j'avais pu faire
dans mes précédentes fonctions en créant
une telle charte un tel contrat
d'engagement mais il aura désormais
valeur de loi et donc nous faisons cela
pour soutenir également les élus locaux
notamment les maires qui sont courageux
et qui veulent faire en sorte de mettre
en place de tels contrats certains élus
locaux ont déjà tenté de mettre en place
ce type de charte qui sont parfois
attaquer en justice par certains acteurs
locaux et donc il est important pour
nous de dire que cela a valeur de loi
et ce sera désormais dans la loi chaque
association devra en prendre
connaissance au moment de la signature
du serfa et donc s'engager à respecter
ses valeurs
maintenant pour définir le texte qui
fera ce contrat d'engagement des
principes républicains
nous lançons avec gérald darmanin deux
cycles de consultation un premier auprès
des représentants des organisations des
élus avec jacqueline gourault la
ministre chargée de la cohésion des
territoires dans les prochaines semaines
nous les recevrons
et changement avec elle et avec eux sur
les grands principes qu'ils souhaitent
voir définir dans ce contrat
d'engagement puisque nous le faisons
aussi pour les aider et pour les
accompagner
et puis d'autre part un cycle de
consultations avec sarah est la hérie ma
collègue qui est chargée de l'engagement
associatif avec laquelle nous recevrons
les grands représentants des
organisations d'associations pour
échanger également avec elle et avec eux
sur le texte de ce contrat d'engagement
qui viendra conforter ses valeurs alors
il permettra ce contrat d'engagement de
faire en sorte qu'on ne donne pas un
euro d'argent public aux ennemis de la
république
mais par ailleurs il pourra aussi faire
en sorte que lorsqu'un élu ou lorsque
l'état qui soit central ou déconcentrés
et donner des subventions on demande le
remboursement rétroactif de l'argent qui
aurait été approché à des associations
qui ne respecteraient pas les valeurs de
la république par exemple qui
discriminerait qui proféraient des
appels à la haine de l'apologie du
terrorisme ou des propos antisémites
j'aimerais également partager avec vous
un bloc important de cette fois sur
lequel nous avons travaillé avec le miso
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et avec
d'autres ministres qui concerne la
dignité humaine il nous semble que le
respect de la dignité humaine le respect
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes fait partie des valeurs de la
république des principes républicains et
nous avons donc décidé d'agir dans
quatre champs sur cette question d'abord
figure dans cette fois l'interdiction
des certificat de virginité plus
exactement nous disons dans cette loi
qui ne sera plus possible d'établir des
certificats médicaux sans lien avec la
santé de la patiente et je voudrais
remercier olivier ferrand ministre de la
santé avec lequel nous avons travaillé
notamment pour échanger avec les acteurs
de terrain nous avons entendu certains
nous dira mais il est difficile pour une
femme qui demande le certificat de
virginité pour une jeune fille de
rentrer dans sa famille sans certificat
c'est à dire si on interdit ces
certificats mais nous nous pensons qu'il
est important que la république se
positionne et nous demandons qu est ce
qui se passe pour une jeune femme dont
l'acte fondateur de son mariage et
d'avoir été envoyé chez un gynécologue
subir un test de virginité
nous pensons que personne dans la
république française n'a justifié de sa
virginité
par ailleurs nous créons un mécanisme de
rattrapage sur les questions de réserver
éditeur nous avons bouclé avec le garde
des sceaux qui détaillera je pense c'est
le souhaitent
cette mesure mais l'idée est là aussi
pour nous est de dire que dans la
république française on ne peut pas
déshériter les filles au profit des
garçons et donc quand cela se passe sur
la base du droit coutumier le droit
français devra permettre de venir
rattraper cela nous décidons de
renforcer la lutte contre les mariages
forcés
ils sont évidemment déjà interdit en
france mais d'après les grandes ong
notamment le gams environ deux cent
mille femmes vivent en france dans un
mariage forcé et donc avec cette loi
nous renforçons le rôle des associations
et des ong qui pourront alerter les
officiers d'état civil lorsqu'elles ont
connaissance de mariage forcé sur le
point de se contracter
l'officier d'état civil procédera à un
entretien individuel avec les deux
futurs potentiels marier pour s'assurer
de leur consentement et aura
l'obligation de procéder à un article 40
auprès du procureur de la république
afin d'empêcher ce mariage de se tenir
sans le consentement de la jeune fille
puisque souvent ce sont les jeunes
filles
enfin dernière mesure nous souhaitons
renforcer la lutte contre la polygamie
la polygamie est déjà interdite en
france mais nous souhaitons protéger les
droits particulièrement des femmes et
faire en sorte que notamment nous
prenions des dispositions en matière de
retraites et pensions de réversion mais
également nous ne donnerons pas de titre
de séjour à des personnes qui sont
polygames et si la situation de la
polygamie et découverte lors d'un
contrôle une fois que la personne est
déjà avec un titre de séjour ce titre de
séjour lui sera retiré
c'est important je me prête je me
permets de faire une précision parce que
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses dans les
médias des gens des témoins dire vous
allez interdire leur fidélité vous à les
interdire le polyamour c'est pas de ça
qu'il s'agit il s'agit vraiment de la
polygamie pourquoi est-ce qu'un mariage
est contracté parce que le mariage il
ouvre un certain nombre de droits
notamment en matière d'héritage en
matière de filiation etc et nous voulons
ainsi protéger les personnes qui
s'engagent dans le mariage et je
voudrais remercier les ministres avec
lesquels nous avons travaillé cela nous
l'éducation nationale le garde des
sceaux est bien évidemment auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur pour conclure
rapidement je voudrais me permettre de
dire que toute l'action menée par l'état
n'est pas évidemment comprise dans cette
fois il ya aussi des choses qui ne
relèvent pas du législatif et c'est
pourquoi avec le ministre de l'intérieur
nous avons intensifié sous l'autorité du
produit serait du présent la république
l'action dclear des cellules de lutte
contre l'islamisme et le repli
communautaire et depuis fin 2010 9 se
sont 3881 contrôles qui ont été menées
par les services de l'état
394 lieux ont été fermées et 25 millions
d'euros ont été redressés ces actions
elle nous semble fondamental nous serons
avec le premier ministre sur le terrain
dès cet après midi avec le ministre de
l'intérieur ni l'éducation nationale
pour nous engager avec les cuirs et nous
voulons faire en sorte que cette action
de fermeture et de fermeté elle soit
complémentaire de l'action menée par
l'ensemble du gouvernement de jean
castex en faveur de l'égalité des
chances qu'il s'agisse du dédoublement
des classes à douze élèves par classe de
la réforme l'accompagnement de
l'orientation scolaire de programme de
rénovation urbaine qui a été porté à 10
milliards d'euros de subventions de
l'anru pour la transformation de 450
quartier la mise en place des sites et
éducative de la police de sécurité du
quotidien de la stratégie de prévention
de la délinquance ou de notre plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi des jeunes un
jeune une solution avec le renfort de la
présence des services publics dans les
quartiers et nous pensons que cela aussi
c'est essentiel et c'est l'action en
tout cas que nous menons au ministère de
l'intérieur et que je mène auprès de
gérald darmanin
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
alors autre acteur majeur de l'écriture
de ce texte le ministre en charge de
l'éducation nationale
merci monsieur le premier ministre
depuis qu'existe la république l'école
est considérée comme la colonne
vertébrale de la de la république c'est
particulièrement vrai avec la
consolidation républicaine de la
troisième république et chacun sait que
cette consolidation a été parallèle avec
la consolidation de l'école ce premier
principe cette première vérité de notre
histoire républicaine se voit dans cette
nouvelle loi qui comme cela a été dit
précédemment est une loi de liberté
une loi qui permet aussi de consolider
l'école de la république
dans notre société du 21ème siècle elle
repose finalement d'abord sur une
première affirmation toute simple mais
qui a particulièrement de valeur dans la
période actuelle c'est que l'école est
bonne pour les enfants nous le savons
dans cette période sanitaire si
particulière il est très important que
les enfants aillent à l'école
c'est pourquoi cette loi s'inscrit aussi
dans l'héritage de ce que nous avons
fait depuis 2010 est puisque nous avons
dans la loi pour l'école de la confiance
établi que l'instruction était
obligatoire à 3 ans nous avons aussi au
travers d'autres dispositions je pense
en particulier à la loi dite gaestel
établi qu' il pouvait y avoir un une
capacité d'empêcher de la part du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
l'ouverture d'une école hors contrat
cela fait partie d'une stratégie donc
général de défense des valeurs de la
république dans notre vie collective
dans cette loi il y a plusieurs
dispositions qui concernent l'école et
qui concerne aussi le sport
je voudrais les évoquer très rapidement
la première est peut-être celle qui a
suscité le plus de commentaires jusqu'à
présent établi la scolarisation
obligatoire à 3 ans autrement dit le
fait que l'instruction a des yeux à
domicile doit être tout à fait
exceptionnelle est entré dans le cadre
d'exception prévue par la loi
la scolarisation obligatoire à 3 ans on
voit ce que je disais précédemment
l'école est bonne pour les enfants elle
renvoie aussi un phénomène de société
qui fait que depuis une dizaine d'années
il y a eu un très grand nombre de
nouvelles de nouveaux cas d'instruction
à domicile et nous voyons que dans un
certain nombre de cas pas tous bien sûr
cela camoufle en réalité non pas une
véritable instruction à domicile mais
par exemple les structures clandestines
salafistes que nous avons fermé lorsque
nous avons fermé ses structures depuis
trois ans et encore récemment avec la
mise de l'intérieur
la moitié des élèves étaient soi-disant
en instruction à domicile
cette réalité sociologique et bien nous
voulons la regarder en face au travers
de cette mesure est donc nous avons
établi que désormais ce t1 un régime
d'autorisation pour l'instruction à
domicile et non pas simplement un régime
déclaratif et les exceptions prévues
pour autoriser l'instruction à domicile
reste circonscrite et doivent permettre
l'instruction à domicile dans les cas
qui sont conformes aux droits de
l'enfant parce que je voudrais insister
sur ce point
il s'agit en l'occurrence non seulement
de défendre la république au travers
d'un tel dispositif
mais de défendre les droits de l'enfant
les deux choses vont ensemble un enfant
qui a trois ou quatre ans ou même
ultérieurement et mis dans une situation
d'endoctrinement et mis dans une
situation inacceptable par la même
occasion
du point de vue de la défense de ses
droits c'est donc une disposition de
défense des droits de l'enfant
les exceptions prévues sont l'état de
santé de l'enfant ou son handicap mais
comme vous le savez nous avons aussi une
politique d' école inclusive pour que
justement les élèves en situation de
handicap ait à l'école il doit y avoir
une raison justifiée
deuxièmement la pratique d'activités
sportives ou artistiques intensive qui
justifie un régime particulier
troisièmement l'itinérance de la famille
en france où l'éloignement géographique
d'un établissement scolaire
enfin en quatrième lieu l'existence
d'une situation particulière propre à
l'enfant sous réserve que les personnes
qui en sont responsables justifient de
leur capacité à assumer l'instruction en
famille dans le respect de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant et donc c'est ce
respect de l'intérieur
supérieur de l'enfant qui sera contrôlée
par les rectorats de façon à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de dérives en la matière
cette première disposition est conforme
aux libertés
je rappelle que plusieurs pays en europe
limite l'instruction à domicile parfois
même l'interdît c'est le cas de
l'allemagne de la suède ou de l'espagne
et la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme n'a pas du tout invalider ces
régimes que l'on connaît en europe
deuxième dispositions importantes
relatives aux réalités scolaire de cette
loi c'est la possibilité désormais pour
l'autorité administrative au sein de
l'éducation nationale donc le ministère
de l'éducation nationale de fermer une
école hors contrat
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la loi gatel
qui a été adopté il ya deux ans elle
nous a permis d'empêcher des ouvertures
d'écoles hors contrat et j'ai ainsi pu
empêcher au cours des 2 dernières
entrées un certain nombre d'ouvertures
des cols hors contrat parce qu'elle
n'était pas conforme aux valeurs de la
république
désormais nous nous donnons le moyen de
fermer administrativement une telle
école alors que jusqu'à présent c'était
au travers du juge pénal
évidemment cette fermeture
administrative se passe sous le contrôle
du juge avec donc toutes les garanties
en matière de libertés mais elle nous
permettra d'être réellement efficace
alors que aujourd'hui les délais sont
très long pour arriver à un tel résultat
il ya aussi d'autres mesures que je vais
évoquer plus rapidement d'abord nous
pourrons désormais procéder à la
consultation du casier judiciaire de
tous les professeurs des établissements
privés hors contrat
ensuite nous pourrons renforcer aussi le
contrôle que nous avons sur les comptes
et les sources de financement des écoles
privées hors contrat
enfin pour la conclusion d'un contrat
simple d'un contrat d'association
nous exigeons le respect d'un
enseignement conforme à l'objet de
l'instruction obligatoire
autrement dit les normes minimales
requises par le code de l'éducation
si je voulais résumé les cinq mesures
dont gène parler notamment les dernières
sur les écoles hors contrat nous pouvons
dire que en cette fin de quinquennat
nous avons vraiment changé une réalité
qui telle qu'elle existait au début du
quinquennat il était au début du
quinquennat plus facile d'ouvrir une
école que d'ouvrir un bar désormais
il y à de véritables règles qui
encadrent cela parce que l'activité
éducative est une éduqué est une
activité évidemment exigeante et qui
doit respecter les droits de l'enfant et
les valeurs de la république
enfin nous prenons aussi un certain
nombre de dispositions dans le domaine
sportif au travers de cette loi et de
mesures complémentaires que nous
prendrons avec roxana maracineanu nous
avons travaillé avec les fédérations
sportives de façon à ce qu'elles
s'engagent expressément au respect des
valeurs de la république au travers des
conventions qui sont conclues avec elle
est donc au travers des fédérations et
les clubs que nous touchons la
délivrance de l'agrément ou de
subventions sera conditionné au respect
des principes républicains
cette évolution législative est conforme
aux désirs qui pouvaient exister dans le
monde du sport pour éviter les dérives
séparatiste et elle s'accompagnera aussi
de toute une série d' accompagnement et
dead au monde sportif pour respecter ses
principes
voilà monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les les principales
mesures qui concerne le champ scolaire
et le chant du sport à l'intérieur de
cette loi et donc comme cela a été dit
je crois que nous sommes en effet dans
la tradition de ces grandes lois de la
république qui permette de préserver nos
libertés en leur donnant un cadre qui
est un cadre justement républicain je
vous remercie
merci monsieur mise éducation nationale
le garde des sceaux bin isa justice a
également apporté une contribution
majeure à ce texte
monsieur dupont moretti merci monsieur
le premier ministre
rappeler les valeurs de la république
mesdames et messieurs s'est rappelé la
liberté et protéger les valeurs de la
république
c'est protéger la liberté c'est une loi
de liberté et je suis fier à la place
qui est la mienne d'y avoir participé
après le discours des mureaux qui était
tellement attendu il fallait que l'on
transforme la parole présidentielle en
actes
c'était notre tasse et nous l'avons
conduite sous la houlette de monsieur le
premier ministre
de longues semaines à consulter à
réfléchir à discuter ensemble et nous
sommes parvenus
c'est le fruit de notre travail
collectif à ce texte que nous avons
aujourd'hui l'honneur de vous présenter
moi je suis parti de la mort de samuel
paty et nous avons regardé dans les
éléments factuels que nous avions ce qui
manquait au dispositif
vous savez que c'est parti d'une vidéo
puis des propos haineux qui sont devenus
des propos mortifère et qui ont conduit
à la mort de cet homme
nous avons donc créé un délit de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui par la
divulgation d'informations relatives à
sa vie privée se délient punira le fait
de révéler de diffuser de transmettre
des informations relatives à la vie
privée familiale professionnelle d'une
personne permettant de l'identifier de
la localiser dans le but et c'est
extrêmement important de l'exposé elle
où les membres de sa famille à un risque
immédiat d'atteinte à la vie ou à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique
ce n'est pas je le dire qu'il n'y ait
aucune confusion un article 25
c'est un article et c'est l'article 18
de ce projet de loi que nous avons créé
un délit qui protègent davantage encore
et c'était bien utile les agents publics
qui se voient menacés par des
séparatistes
ça ce sont les dispositions principales
du code pénal et puis il y à des
dispositions de la procédure pénale
la première disposition elle est
extrêmement importante
elle a pour but de lutter et bien sûr de
lutter efficacement contre la haine en
ligne il s'agit de permettre à des gens
qui diffusent aujourd'hui impunément la
haine qui la distille sur les réseaux
sociaux d'être immédiatement interpellé
et jugé dans le cadre d'une comparution
immédiate qu'il n'y ait aucune confusion
dans quelques esprits que ce soit les
journalistes ne sont en aucune façon
visés par ce texte et nous avons
travaillé pour exclure les journalistes
de cette disposition de procédure pénale
sur ce que l'on appelle je ne veux pas
être trop technique
mais les journalistes qui sont ici
connaît ça mieux que moi la
responsabilité en cascade la deuxième
disposition du code de procédure pénale
et les relatives à l' inscrit à
l'inscription aux fillettes qui va être
étendu pour ceux qui sont l'auteur d'
apologie d'actes de terrorisme
et puis il y à un certain nombre de
dispositions civiles que nous portons
ensemble bien sûr certaines relatives au
mariage forcé dans notre république
on peut aimer qui on veut et le concept
consentement est un oui qui doit
toujours être éclairé bien sûr la
deuxième disposition de droit civil et
relatives à l'héritage madame schiappa
vous en a parlé
je vais être donc très bref sur cette
question il n'est plus question que dans
notre pays une fille n'hérite pas comme
un garçon au seul motif que c'est une
fille enfin la dernière disposition que
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter et
relatives aux blocages
les sites illégaux miroir le texte que
nous souhaitons voir porter que nous
allons porter prochainement devant le
parlement reprendra une disposition de
la loi avia sur le retrait automatique
des sites miroirs voilà mesdames et
messieurs ce que sommairement et a
évidemment un certain nombre d'autres
dispositions je souhaitais aujourd'hui
vous exposer merci beaucoup monsieur le
garde des sceaux avec les ministres donc
nous nous tenons maintenant à votre
disposition pour répondre à quelques
questions même si nous aurons tout à
loisir
l'occasion d'expliquer ce projet de loi
dans les jours et les semaines à venir
alors je vous écoute
bonjour s'amuse taxi pour le canal + ses
news
ma première question pour vous monsieur
le premier ministre vous avez évoqué un
travail de préparation intense de ce
projet ces derniers mois est ce que le
calendrier était judicieux alors même
que l'on est entré dans une séquence
sanitaire inédite et que l'unité
nationale est demandée force est de
constater que ce texte divise fortement
jusqu'au sein de la majorité
présidentielle est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
fallu concentrer votre action sur la
sortie de crise dans laquelle nous
sommes
crise sanitaire et crise sociale et puis
une question au ministre de l'intérieur
vous avez dit qu'il ne sera plus
possible d'observer des comportements
communautaires ou des port de signes
religieux pour les agents qui
travaillent au nom du service public
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser la
définition d'un comportement
communautaire merci beaucoup
on va prendre plusieurs questions
comment fait d'habitude et puis nous
répartir les rôles janak eu à très bien
bonjour agnani ce boom de bloomberg news
une question pour monsieur ministre de
l'intérieur l'année dernière vous étiez
élevées contre ce que vous avez appelé
liste communautaire et vous aviez
demandé des mesures pour un respect
strict de la laïcité par les élus locaux
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a suffisamment avancé sur
ce sujet et quand on parle de liste
communautaire en général on ne parle que
d'un parti finalement c'est l'union des
démocrates musulmans de france qui est
tout petit que leur reprochez vous
exactement
allez encore une ou deux questions qu'on
va répondre à la première série bonjour
maxence lambrecq e france inter qu'avez
vous retenu de l'avis du conseil d'état
c'est globalement et précisément sur la
question des personnes condamnées pour
apologie du terrorisme ou discrimination
il y aura t'il toujours question d'une
interdiction de paraître dans les lieux
de culte
une sorte de double peine en tout cas
après la condamnation de l'interdiction
de renan lieux de culte bonjour julie
marie lecomte france info vous nous avez
rappelé les mesures déjà engagées en
matière de cohésion sociale en
expliquant que vous mener une stratégie
globale
au delà de ceux de ce projet de loi est
ce que vous comptez aller aller plus
loin avec de nouvelles mesures en
matière d'égalité des chances et de
lutte contre les discriminations très
bien je vous je vous propose frangins
vite le musée intérieur à s'approcher
puisque principales questions lui
étaient destinées je voudrais répondre à
la toute première et à la toute dernière
en ce qui me concerne d'abord sur la
question du moment et du calendrier
j'ai envie de vous dire que
il n'est jamais trop tôt pour s'occuper
de défendre les valeurs de la république
donc
le moment est bien venu il est conforme
aux objectifs y compris calendaire que
nous nous étions fixés et surtout d'une
part je ne crois en rien que cette loi
va diviser
je pense au contraire que c'est une loi
qui va permettre d'unir beaucoup de
forces politiques qui sont comme le
gouvernement attaché aux principes
républicains et au delà des forces
politiques les françaises et français
la deuxième chose que je souhaite vous
dire c'est que la discussion de ce texte
préparation d'abord nous nous a en rien
distrait de notre énergie à gérer la
crise sanitaire
la crise économique et sociale la france
vous le savez pas quel mais la france en
particulier est effectivement confronté
à plusieurs défis concomitants il ya
donc la crise sanitaire que vous évoquez
avec toutes les conséquences économiques
et sociales qu'elle entraîne
puis oui il ya eu aussi ce n'est qu'à 20
personnes des attentats très grave
il est du devoir et de responsabilité du
gouvernement de la république sous
l'autorité du chef de l'état de prendre
les mesures et dispositions que chacune
de ces crises appel et c'est ce que je
crois nous faisons ne sont pas toujours
simples elles ne sont pas toujours
évidentes mais elles nous paraissent
nécessaires et nous sommes en
responsabilité pour agir avec un
objectif commun est transversal à pour
faire face à ces trois situations la
volonté d'apaiser d'expliquer toujours
et encore
et surtout d'être efficace cette
efficacité par rapport aux sujets qui
nous réunit ce matin je les dis et je le
répète suppose que nous agissions sur
tous les terrains
j'avais presque dire c'est notre marque
de fabrique pas y avoir une seule
approche
mesdames et messieurs qui traite des
problèmes aussi complexes pas opposer la
proche sécuritaire l'apprenant nous
devons agir sur tous les terrains et
c'est ce que nous faisons et c'est ce
que nous faisons
alors vous me m'interroger si nous avons
l'intention de renforcer encore les
dispositions que nous prenons visant à
assurer la cohésion sociale à renforcer
l'égalité des chances à réponse est
positive parce que de la même façon que
nous pourrions démontrer que cette loi
s'inscrit dans un continuum avons déjà
pris des dispositions notamment en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
nous allons poursuivre notre travail par
l'adoption de textes mais cela a été dit
à plusieurs reprises de l'action
publique ne se résume pas à des textes
nous conduisons des politiques publiques
dans un cadre concerté avec tous les
acteurs vous savez que j'ai reçue
récemment par exemple les mères qui nous
avait écrit sur des sujets des quartiers
de la politique de la ville les
associations
donc oui nous présenterons des actions
complémentaires dans la continuité de
celles que nous avons déjà engagé
monsieur demi d'intérieur merci monsieur
le premier ministre et non trois
questions sont posées de la question des
listes communautaire et et d'un parti
est évoqué mais pas faire des choses à
2000m la question du comportement
communautaire et sa définition et la
question date indique sont pas dans les
lieux de culte et en complément de ce
qu'a dit monsieur le garde des sceaux 6
me le permet sur le premier point
moi je m'inquiète et je me suis inquiété
je crois que c'était le cas également du
ministre l'intérieur précédent de la
revendication politique au nom du
religieux et de l'entrisme c'est ce que
nous dénonçons lorsque nous disons qu'il
faut distinguer la religion de la
politique et de l'entrisme que certains
peuvent voir dans les élections
démocratiques et singulièrement les
élections démocratiques locales et qu'
il s'agit pas de punir des délits
d'opinion ou des partis politiques que
la république d'ailleurs accepte quand
bien même elle les combats ces deux
principes d'une démocratie contrairement
à un régime qui n'est pas démocratique
mais de pouvoir avoir des garde-fous
pour éviter un certain nombre de
comportements que la république les
principes de ré but la loi que votre le
parlement ci dessous est en l'amendant
des comportements qui nous apparaissent
communautariste prison à appliquer
utiliser le mot de séparatistes il me
semble madame que réserver des horaires
pour des femmes ou pour des hommes sont
des motifs religieux ne sont pas
compatibles avec les valeurs de la
république
en ce qui concerne un endroit qui est
payé par l'argent public
il ya aujourd'hui il ya eu ou le savez
bien des règlement intérieur voté par
des élus ou mis en place par des actes
unilatéraux d'administration qui ont
permis de réserver des horaires de
piscine mais aussi d'autres endroits
publics pour des motifs religieux
la religion n'a rien à voir avec nos
semble-t-il les actions des pouvoirs
publics locaux
la réplique ne reconnaît aucun culte et
leur permet à chacun de s'exprimer mais
qu'elle le fasse dans la limite de la
neutralité du service public
et si nous devons nous inquiéter des
listes comme de terre politiquement nous
devons condamner en revanche des actes
ou des comportements communautaires
lorsqu'il arrive et c'est bien ce que
nous avons voulu renforcer notamment par
les dispositions du référé liberté que
nous mettons à la disposition des
préfets référé liberté parce que ça va
vite
48 heures il n'y a pas de débat a fini
pour savoir si cela est ou n'est pas
conforme aux valeurs républicains et
puis le juge choisira il s'agit pas
simplement d'un acte unilatéral de
l'administration centrale si j'ose dire
le deuxième sujet évoqué c'est le
comportement communautaire
loi vise à renforcer les principes de
1905 sans les étendre abusivement je
m'explique la neutralité qu'elle soit
politique ou religieuse est une
condition sinequanone des agents publics
qui travaillent tant dans les
collectivités locales que dans l'état un
agent du service d'état civil d'une
mairie n'a pas à porter de signes
distinctifs religieux ou politiques à
tenir des propos religieux au politique
et n'a pas à demander l'aménagement de
ces horaires où un certain nombre de
comportements au nom de principes
religieux et politiques
en revanche le texte de loi ne vise pas
à neutraliser l'espace public le citoyen
qui va dans l'accueil de cette mairie
pour rencontrer le fonctionnaire qui à
qui l'on doit cette neutralité lui a le
droit de porter un signe ostensible
religieux le droit de tenir un certain
nombre de comportements que n'ont pas à
prendre les agents du service public est
l'une des difficultés que nous avons
connues en comprenant bien que nous ne
revenons pas sur cette distinction
importante espaces publics agents du
service public service public vie en
société et que l'état les collectivités
locales a de plus en plus c'est la vie
économique et collectivités locales
délégué assemble de mission qu'il
faisait en direct et transport
l'ordination de piscine et marché et ça
peut être le cas aussi pour l'état qui a
donné un sens d'une structure notamment
sociales des puissances de prérogatives
de puissance publique pardon sans être
aujourd'hui strictement ce en sus des
fonctionnaires ou des agents de l'état
et on s'est donc aperçu mais le conseil
d'état l'a d'ailleurs relevé que ces
agents de transport par exemple il
travaillait pour une société de
transport qui travaille au nom d'une
agglomération ne sont pas soumis au même
statut que l'agent public alors qu'ils
font une mission de service public qui
exige la neutralité
un don qui ne sera plus possible si la
loi est adoptée par le parlement que des
agents par exemple la société de
transport portent des signes ostensibles
religieux il ne sera plus possible
qu'ils demandent l'aménagement
d'horaires à leur employeur pour des
motifs religieux
il ne sera pas possible d'organiser une
salle de prière
il ne sera pas possible de s'interdire
ou de demander c'est ce qui peut parfois
arrivé j'étais vice président aux
transports de mon agglomération pendant
trois ans de ne pas pouvoir travailler
avec une femme ou avec quelqu'un d'une
autre confession
et donc nous allons appliquer aux agents
qui sont missionnés au nom du service
public mais qui ne sont pas
fonctionnaires les mêmes cadres que nous
demandons aux fonctionnaires parce qu'il
annonce à centre d'action de service
public ce texte de loi ne revient pas
dans la vie du travail privé dans un
entreprise privée il ya des règles qui
peuvent être regardés mais elle concerne
les employeurs et des employés dans un
cadre de discussions sociales dans
lesquelles l'état n'intervient pas
troisième sujet interdiction de paraître
alors le juge peut toujours prononcé
comme comme d'habitude si je veux dire d
interdiction de paraître
c'est sa responsabilité propre en
revanche peut-être est-ce votre question
nous avons considéré que le garde des
sceaux qu' il y avait un fichier il nous
apparaît finalement le fige est alors
cette parallèle du fis ges luffy ges
vous le connaissez parfois c'est le
fichier des délinquants sexuels
et même lorsqu'on a terminé sa peine un
maire aujourd'hui demandent en général
au service de monsieur misé question
nationale ou aux préfets de savoir s'il
peut embaucher telle ou telle personne
pour s'occuper des enfants dans une
commune et c'est à bon droit qu'il a le
droit de refuser ce contrat si cette
personne est dans le fichier des
délinquants sexuels
même quand il a épuisé sa peine chacun
le comprend nous en sommes nous
instaurons cette même possibilité en
disant qu' une disposition spécifique du
projet de loi est évoquée mais j'ai
voulu aller rapidement pour pas rentrer
dans le détail mais comme poser la
question j'y réponds aucune personne en
france une fois que la loi sera adoptée
ne pourra être dans le bureau dans le
conseil d'administration en dirigeant
d'un lieu de culte quel qu'il soit
s'y est inscrit au fichier est le
fichier des personnes condamnées pour
terrorisme
ce fichier sera demain a grandi par les
apologie du terrorisme nous avons eu
malheureusement fleurir
un certain nombre de jugements à la
suite de l'assassinât horrible de
monsieur patty est par ailleurs dans se
fige et il ya aussi des mises en examen
pas simplement les condamner il nous
paraissait normal bonne hygiène de vie
démocratique que des gens qui dirigent
les lieux de culte n'est jamais été
condamnées de plus loin pour acte de
terrorisme
c'était le bon sens mais qui n'était pas
celui de la loi merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre j'ai omis de répondre à une
question relative à l'avis du conseil
d'état je ne sais plus qui me la pose et
je suis désolé je vais le faire tout de
suite donc le concept a nous a rendu un
avis extrêmement précis extrêmement
fouillé extrêmement circonstanciés qui
est effectivement particulièrement utile
au gouvernement il n'a proposé de
disjoindre je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez cette formule qui marque d
accord du conseil d'état par rapport à
des dispositions qui lui sont soumises
aucune des dispositions de ce texte ce
qui est un point pour nous extrêmement
important ce cet avis sera public vous
constaterez que le gouvernement l'a en
très très large part suivi ce qui est
aussi s'agissant des textes relatifs aux
libertés publiques fondamentales une
garantie aussi je crois pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens
alors je suis désolé mais nous allons
être appelé par un exercice démocratique
puisqu'il ya des questions au
gouvernement au sénat alors je veux bien
prendre deux dernières questions 2 et
après nous levons la séance parce que
nous sommes appelés à d'autres activités
monsieur jean libre ou pour un pour
europe 1 vous luttez contre une
idéologie en combien de temps
pensez-vous que cette loi changera
réellement les choses est-ce que vous
avez d un peu des perspectives à donner
aux français et puis j'aurais juste
relayer une question de riz mantas de
politico est-ce que ce projet de loi ne
risque pas d'être une nouvelle loi de
2004 sur les signes ostentatoires est-ce
qu'il faut pas être plus précis pour
éviter à des amalgames des procès
d'intention je fais court
oui allez dernière qu'elle suit une
formation de premier ministre bonjour
madame et messieurs les ministres matile
de sirop pour le figaro je voudrais
simplement compléter la question de ma
consoeur julie marie lecomte
vous n'avez pas les deux dispositions
complémentaires concernant le logement
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
nouveau texte sur ce sujet précisément
et est ce que vous vous engagez comme
vous eu envie de certains responsables
de la majorité a présenté un plan
gouvernemental de lutte contre les
discriminations et pour l'égalité des
chances qui viendraient en même temps
que le projet de loi au parlement donc
tranché fin janvier début février
merci alors répondre directement
n'arrête lorraine parce qu'après on sera
retard mais en se tiendra à votre
disposition rassurez vous monsieur le le
s'agissant du logement
nous avions dans le texte initial envoyé
au conseil tu as prévu de prendre ses
dispositions par ordonnance et compte
tenu des avis qui sont exprimés et de la
volonté d'avoir une concertation nous
avons sorti ces dispositions du projet
de loi dont nous vous entretenez
aujourd'hui pour en faire comme je les
dis dans mon propos liminaire des textes
à part entière qui seront donc présentés
le moment venu par le gouvernement est
préparée par la ministre en charge du
logement emmanuelle wargon donc il y à
bien là aussi comme sur le reste
la volonté d'agir et je les dis aussi à
une réponse à une question par donc
précédentes nous voulons aussi prendre
est ce que ce sera nécessairement encore
une fois des dispositions de nature
législative ce n'est pas certain en tout
cas des mesures relatives au
renforcement de la cohésion sociale et
de l'égalité des chances et cela viendra
dans les prochaines semaines bon vous
m'avez sa première question savoir si
cette loi était suffisante si dans
quelques uns combien de temps elle
produirait des effets c'est un texte
fort appel à tout le monde c'est un
texte extrêmement important c'est pas le
premier c'est pas le dernier vous avez
sans doute raison
enfin il me semble qu'il ya longtemps
que l'on ne s'était pas attaqué de
manière aussi résolu à des problèmes de
vie quotidienne de nos de nos
concitoyens et j insiste dans le respect
de ce que sont nos valeurs fondatrices
de celle qui nous réunissent à toutes et
à tous
alors sûrement que le débat
parlementaire améliorera encore
discussion parlementaire améliorera
encore y compris show terrain de
l'effectivité des dispositions que nous
proposons m'enfin je vous signale quand
même que nous utilisons déjà tous les
dispositifs à notre un autre main si je
puis dire pour agir voyez que déjà nous
avons dissous un certain nombre de
groupements de fait ou d'associations
fermé des des mosquées qui intervenait
dans l'illégalité
voilà donc ce texte il va venir accéléré
il va venir conforter nous y croyons
beaucoup c'est un texte très important
c'est un moment fort je le dis c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs nous
avons souhaité solenniser ce moment par
la présentation du projet de loi dès son
adoption par le conseil des ministres et
nous allons comme vous en suivre le
cheminement devant le parlement l entrée
en vigueur dans le pays
je vous remercie beaucoup
oh